each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
schedule I got a little
okay my name is Dennis Gannon and this
is a joint work with my colleague Beth
play Lee who is just over here sitting
down actually its joint work with a
whole bunch of people it's about a
hundred people actually is a hundred
people from a bunch of universities the
lead of the project is Kelvin drug
admire at the University of Oklahoma and
this is a got a whole bunch of different
experts in a lot of different areas and
after years of kissing a lot of frogs
we've this this has really worked out
really well it's an exciting project and
what so what is it this is a project to
understand to change the paradigm for
research and mesoscale meteorology so
what is meso scale whether it's
tornadoes it's hurricanes it is really
horrible things that happen very quickly
without a lot of warning and they're
very hard to predict and they are as as
you may have noticed those of us in the
states we've been sort of living in a
sea of news about mesoscale meteorology
now for the last month or so but those
of us from the Midwest know that this is
every year is a big problem particular
tornadoes are even more difficult to
predict than hurricanes and the
Hurricanes even generate tornadoes are
really complicated stuff now here's the
problem that in the traditional
meteorology they have a way of doing
things and it's just not cutting it
these are desperate people they want to
be able to make predictions of a storm
that is so accurate that people will
believe the predictions this is a big
serious problem people say oh you know
they say the storms come in but I don't
know I'll stay here if people would have
faith in the predictions that are made
if the science were that good and the
policymakers had access to the right
information lives can be saved but the
problem with the current meteorology
mechanisms is it is it is it's a very
very linear process yes
static observations which are done a
regular basis go through state of
simulation do some some large-scale
computation get a result and predict
something it's a very static chain of
events it's it's entirely cereal and
pre-scheduled that's and in particular
to in order to change the paradigm this
pre-scheduled nature of the computation
is not good enough for us to be able to
make the truly precise measurements on
the fly decisions that we have to make
so what is really important as we have
to be as I'll explain here we have to be
you have to introduce adaptivity in the
whole computational model we have to be
adaptive in response to the way we deal
with the data storms happen you can't
you once you detect something is
happening that's when you should start
triggering interesting computations you
also have to as you see in a second
close the loop with instruments and I'll
explain what that means in a minute you
have to be able to be very adaptive in
the way you use computational resources
too because things change and storms
happen and you need more resources than
you might have otherwise thought you did
and in particular you have to rethink
the whole day to deluge we call it the
data deluge as opposed to the data
avalanche one is being buried the other
one is drowning same bad news both ways
so here's this this notion of the the
fixed current way of doing things in
adapt to in weather prediction you have
a big giant grid that is completely
static that has rectangles that sort of
encompass like a New England area four
or five states in one grid cell it just
is not going to give you really accurate
information what they're going to now
and what these researchers are now
capable of is truly dynamic computations
that will take a look at weather
patterns and take different regions and
based on that what's happening the way
particularly focus the computation more
intensely in that area with adaptive
grids and furthermore these grids as the
weather change
this what excuse me as the weather
changes the grids themselves should
change so this is avid apptivity of the
computation focusing the computational
effort on the area of interest is has
implications in the way you use the
computational resources because it
changes dynamically the usage pattern
and I'll say some more about that later
the next thing that is really
interesting is their current radars that
are out there are also have some new
capabilities these new next-generation
Doppler radars are actually can be
adaptive themselves that you can
dynamically steer them you say something
is interesting going on over there
refocus and give me more data about that
spot and not so much over there where
nothing is happening this is very
important so the vision for this project
then is to this closing of the loop
between the observation the data
analysis where you do a lot of data
mining and data simulation the actual
prediction which is a large-scale
computation simulation and to use to
close the loop whereby a large-scale
computation so here's the scenario let
me back up the scenario is you have it
you have some instruments feeding data
to say a Data Miner the Data Miner
detects something interesting going on
in the weather says I see a pattern here
the pattern from the Data Miner then
triggers some computation which starts
up a set of simulations a whole
collection we call them ensemble
forecasts of possibilities for what
could happen in this area where
something is detected you use that data
to feed back to the simulations as the
weather is evolving you see what's
interesting and then if things really
get interesting you have the simulations
tell the instruments on the ground to
refocus their attention that closing of
the loop with the instruments is what
these guys would really love to do can't
do it yet but that's where this project
needs to go it's a really hard problem
so to reach this goal we love the things
here's what we discovered along the way
say my colleague Beth realized this long
before I did I sort of got hit over the
head with this because I'm a compute guy
and now I realize that really the real
challenge is understanding the role of
the data and Beth it will give it
another talk about a whole bunch of data
issues tomorrow so I'm not going to say
a lot about that but the data comes from
streams from mining simulations and
visualizations we've got to enable
discovery because in order to do this
sort of work the scientists that are
trying to build these sort of adaptive
scenario scenario scenarios they need to
be able to understand the role of the
experiments they conduct east science
experiments they do it all the time they
analyze data they reanalyze data they
try different scenarios different
workflows they need we need to enable
that we also have to create sort of an
educational context because it's an NSF
project that our plan is that anybody
students you know high school students
college students should be able to
interact with the weather is what Kelvin
keeps saying I interact by the weather
by going outside but they want students
to be able to actually get on to this
system and be able to try out scenarios
themselves to really understand the
weather so to do all of this what we've
realized early on is we really need this
agile architecture of composable
services in order to really make things
dynamic to be able to put things
together in different ways and that our
data is very distributed it comes from
instruments all over the place radar
instruments of ground sensing
instruments balloon instruments
commercial aircraft all this stuff comes
together and it's very distributed and
the computational resources in order to
do the computing we want to do we have
to use the terror grid which is very big
distributed computational resource all
that says is that basically all the
standard grid stuff applies here
distributed resource allocation robust
scalable services and security it's all
important so and the access to this
because of the educational requirements
should be very easy so this is the
architecture now this is I'm not going
to try to go into this in any detail but
but the way we see this evolving is that
the grid
world is building a whole set of
services out there that if they can get
these services built in a standard way
we can we could use them right now some
of these services are available some of
the data services available from the
grid world security services information
services a little bit of job management
but for the application layer you need
you need a lot of service not a lot
actually only about five different
services are required to actually manage
things to manage the computations and
the data and these these are services
that sit above these core services we
call them gateway services and I'll be
describing what some of these are it's
all controlled from this portal now to
give you an idea of what the bit and the
portal is the gateway it's the entry
point for this scientist and in our case
this lead portal allows a scientist a
login actually when they come to it they
see the whether they can log in they
could see the computational resources
they have access to standard
visualization tools the acts have access
to workflow tools as well and we'll talk
a little bit about all of those but as
soon as they login and this is very
important what they see is data they see
their data they see all the experiments
they've run and this is something that
Beth will say more about might say more
about it later but it is really central
to everything we do in lead you log in
you see your data space you see a
history of all the computations you see
this is sort of a browsable interface to
something is really query based and once
you start drilling down in this you
start to look at one experiment you
start to see everything about that
experiment and this is very important
you see a complete provenance of all the
actions that took place in that
experiment and you can recover each
individual step if you want and we use
it and I'll say more about that in a
second whoops so now how do we how do we
compose these services to really build
applications and so this is where the
workflow part of this comes in is that
everything we have is data-driven okay
and so we have to be able to the weather
is a lot of stream information and that
really defines the nature of the
computation it's got to be very
persistent and agile
might start a workflow that is that is
designed to be able to process a certain
type of tornado in a certain event and
and it may sit for weeks or months
without being triggered so it's got to
be a very persistent workflow but
waiting to be triggered waiting to be
enacted and then it's also got to be
adaptive because guess what the weather
changes the nature of the work flow may
have to change on the fly there's kind
of an interesting research problem there
from a CS perspective and that the
weather guys say but we might have a
workflow and it might start running and
then the weather might change in a
really weird way and then we got to
change the workflow so okay that's very
hard but interesting and resources come
and go and so you have to be very
adaptive there too so the way we do this
is we like to we're building on
standards as much as possible everything
is a web service here our applications
are set up as web services the resource
brokers our web services the workflow
itself is a web service and we're
building on basically people which is
the standard that for web service
workflow and actually we're just now
getting the people's stuff deployed we
have a grid version of people called
geeble and that takes advantage of you
know just been slightly modified from
people to take advantage of a lot of the
notification stuff that we're doing
which I'll explain we also have a simple
Python script version of the workflow
which is a sort of a temporary thing but
the idea is that once you start a
workflow the workflow then starts
running or weights to run once it's
triggered it starts interacting with the
the services the services are
applications and we have something
called an application factory which the
workflow talks to to create an instance
of an application I'll describe in a
second what these applications are but
these are the raw components of the
workflow now another very important
thing that I'm going to point out is we
have a notion of events that is part of
this and that is a really another core
the stuff in blue
or the persistence services that are
really important for us and in eventing
we use WS eventing as our main channel
for all information that flows around
our distributed system now about what
applications are so here's some of these
application services and what we get
from the scientists are big Fortran
codes or big c codes and we could tell
them now would you please rewrite these
with the following computer science
distributed systems principles in mind
forget it they won't do that they can't
afford to do that so what you have to do
is take their applications and if you
want them to use it in a way that is
sort of composable what we do is build a
web service that is capable of executing
that application and it's pretty simple
idea and actually it's been done by a
number of different groups in different
ways but the types of applications I
don't know if you can read this but the
things like the the we have one web
service it does the it's called a task
generates 3d gridded analysis takes all
the input from from different
instruments in and produces initial
conditions for a simulation and we've
got data converters of all sorts of
types to convert from this a task form
to something called warf warf is their
simulation model of the weather guys
this is their community code that
they've developed so we have a worth of
service and and so and there's a whole
bunch more there's maybe we've got about
40 50 different services at this point
applications that we've wrapped up as
services and that's pretty easy to do
then we have a tool which only a few
small number of people would actually
use the people that really understand
how to compose these applications most
users come in they never see workflows
they see an application an application
could be just a workflow they don't know
it but that's what it's doing so they
everybody likes a drop and drag
interface I I could give atmospheric
scientists people those of you that know
everybody's seen people here I imagine
yeah many of you have you don't give
that to a scientist right it's a bunch
of XML craziness and they say no no I
just want this to connect to this to
back to this so we wrote a little tool
because ever likes
drop a drag thing so there's no nothing
original about this is just a tool which
allows them to a little palette in the
drop and drag this stuff it's really a
compiler it generates people and it just
generates a small subset of people so
it's it they like it a lot so here's for
example one of flow for a typical
simulation for a weather condition now
this is actually a lot more complicated
looking than it really is many of these
boxes are just different types of data
input the boxes that that I have the
sort of solid yellow in the middle or
actual real computational components and
so they designed this know they put this
together yeah that's it that's it and
for them this replaced like a hundred
thousand line perl script that nobody
could modify was it something like that
Beth you remember how big that script
was big 5000k I had doubled in my mind
I've 50,000 like Perl script but it
really excited because now they have
this and they can change it around
easily it's very nice so here's actually
here's an output from that seemed that
that workflow that they did for Katrina
by taking and this is typical of
experiments they do this was done after
Katrina had already hit but they wanted
to really they have all the data
everything from Katrina everything that
led up to it they know all about it they
know what happened to it and so this is
running that workflow I just showed you
using the input data for Katrina and
then the workflow generates the output
product different types of
visualizations there's a 3d
visualization package that is like to
use or standard 2d viz stuff and so they
can run it they can analyze it they can
play it again they can try different
things in the simulation they can change
the workflow that's the experimental
process that they like oh yeah how do we
wrap up these out by time I don't think
I have time for this 30 seconds anyway
we have wrap up these things as a please
Leah see applications and services it's
really pretty simple tool you basically
we have a tool that allows an app allows
a scientist to describe the application
as an XML form we're
got to make a web form to them to do it
because they don't even like writing XML
at all but it's called a service map
document and you give that to our
factory and it just generates a service
it generates the wisdom for it registers
the Wizzle starts it up my two-minute
warning so let's go on let's skip that
skip that ah this is really critical all
of our services spew out events they
keep track of everything they do
including when they fail it's a great
important debugging tool for distributed
systems because these services are
running all over the place so each one
of them generates a notification the
workflow engine listens to these
notifications the data system the
metadata catalog records all of these
events that's very important for being
able to do replaying experiments you can
go back and you can see everything that
happened you could replay it experiment
exactly with this by tracking the events
so here's an example this is one that
was done actually to test this up this
is a set of services that were written
by our data mining colleagues at another
university and they put together this is
their part of the project and they put
together a little workflow for doing the
data mining feature extraction from some
of the radar data and it gives you an
idea here's this thing as green there
and yellow there this is actually
showing you can watch the workflow in
real time although most workflows take
so long to run you don't want to do that
but a lot of them like that but you can
you can use the tool to watch it here's
the output of just from the first
feature extraction service the first
chain in this workflow it's being
recorded in our metadata catalog my lead
it's called all of the data all of these
events and so you see some of them are
really you know it's just all the detail
it gives you everything about that thing
and and furthermore it can actually lead
down to the last event as usually
visualizations that you can click on it
and see them so to conclude that this
lead project is great it's got this
amazing set of requirements the
architecture that we've come up with is
really a result of these
requirements and it it's like many of
these other i call them gateway
architectures it's a way to put some
useful tools in the hands of a user that
really underneath it all is a big
distributed system for successful the
scientists will never see the
distributed system they don't want to
see it they want to just run the
applications they don't want to care
where the data is stored they want they
want access to it they want to be able
to search for it and discover it so we
have this fusion of data management and
workflow that's really been very
interesting to see how that works this
adaptivity requirement is really making
us rethink what a workflow should look
like and we haven't solved that problem
yet because this whole problem of what
if I want to change the workflow or stop
it and modify it and we don't know how
to do that yet but but that's where
we're we're working hard with them so
that's that's it so I don't yes right
right right so what we see is that some
of the is that there's a group of the
scientists that are the hardcore that
are doing these experiments with
adaptivity these are the core
meteorologists and they want to be able
to get in there and fiddle with the
workflow stop it and change it while
it's running and they need to see all
those tools there's there's another
category of users that just you know
they want to run standard workflow
number 27 with three different for
different data sets at different times
different parameter settings to see if
they're really understanding the
significance of certain parameters in
the workflow and so they don't want to
change it but they see it as an
application and they're not going to try
to modify it on the fly but if they need
to it's there each one of our from our
portal you bring up this as an
application a workflow is just an
application you see a interface to plug
in parameters and then that instantiates
the workflow if I tell them you're gonna
run a workflow they don't even like to
hear that they just want to see an
application how does that answer your
question really okay all right yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah well we're looking at WS
reliability is one thing we're doing the
other thing is is actually scalability
because we've discovered actually that
if you start running this at scale with
the event densities that we have and
having one little WS event channel
sitting on a you know a box someplace
doesn't work so we're really looking at
this whole scalability of the event mode
we haven't you know we haven't really
solved the problem yet right now you
know I would say for the level of users
we have we haven't gone to a large-scale
user base but we're going to have to
I've got actually a couple of students
who told them their PhD project is going
to be understand scalability and
reliability of this sort of stuff and
they're out scouring the literature
right now
figure out what it is that we we don't
know because we're kind of scratching a
long you know by our intuition here
there's not a lot of literature on how
to scale eventing in reliability and you
you guys probably can tell me all sorts
of good things about that we're just
sort of that hit us on over the head and
and we're working on it